in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Dan and
Rachel are with us hey guys how are ya
we're doing awesome good to have you who
are you guys from Kansas City all right
very fun the Missouri side I got it yeah
it's really important if you're there
you get all kinds of trouble if you say
you're on the wrong side now fun fun and
who are these young ladies with you
this is Esperanza and Esther ah very
cool and how old are they
11 and 8 awesomeness very cool well good
to have them with you and so how much
debt has this family paid off about a
hundred and thirty-four thousand
Wow and how long did that take forever
almost 10 years just shy of 10 years in
years Wow and your range of income
during those years we started out at
about 63,000 and ended up at about a
hundred and three thousand way to go
what do you guys do for a living
I work for the government for US Customs
and I take care of nine children oh well
we only have two under 18 now still in
the home but you know I called in very
early in the process and was worried
about how are we gonna speed this up and
you said you know you've just got a lot
of little birdies in the house yeah you
got a lot of mouths yes sir that's what
you told us and so we took it easy and
just stayed on it okay
Oh what kind of debt was the hundred and
thirty-four thousand we had school debt
mortgage just includes mortgage paid off
your house house is paid too early on
early on we paid off credit cards that's
a long journey ten years but nine kids a
lot of mouths to feed while you were
doing it and now you got got them most
of them out of the nest
yep that's a good thing very good so uh
what started the journey ten years ago
well back when you first came on the
radio in Kansas City I had been
listening to the show that was on before
you and one day she was gone and you
were there and it only took me a couple
days to realize this is a good deal so I
got a copy of your book and I asked
Rachel to read it and it took her about
one night to read it and we were fired
up we were ready to go from then on here
we go huh okay he came home with the
book and I thought it looks like some
sort of a self-help thing and I thought
I
I heard of you and I thought oh dear but
then I read it that night and by the
time you got home from work the next day
I had like a 12 page Excel spreadsheet
of where we were gonna go we're both
kind of nerds yeah I think yeah Wow way
to go you guys that's so fun
well congratulations something very
proud of you I mean that's a long slog
10 years how do you stick with it 10
years you just have to keep things in
perspective and realize that that in the
end it's gonna be worth it mm-hmm that's
that's the bottom line
yeah and baby goals there were a lot of
you know let's get this kid graduated
from because all of our children went
through Christian school so let's get
this kid graduated debt-free and then
let's get to this wedding debt-free and
this kid out of Christian College
debt-free and you know it's lots of
little goals yeah so you catch flowing a
lot of stuff while you're doing this
yeah or the mounts - yeah very cool
well congratulations what's your advice
to someone with a large family like
you've had that's listening because I
got a question all the time you can do
this you've got a large family I going
you can't you can't it's just gonna it
may take a while but what's your advice
I think it's what Rachel just said to
make it break it up in bite-sized pieces
make it make it small goals that you can
meet and move on from there and get the
kids on board it was important that they
understood that we're not going to do
that because we're doing this this year
and this is our goal one of our children
got cancer during this time she's doing
great now but for two and a half years
we were dealing with extra medical
expenses and we just all had to
understand that this is our project
right now this is what God's given us
and we're gonna go with it
Wow Wow yeah you've cash flowed a lot of
stuff I mean schools and cancer and my
goodness gracious well very very cool
we're gonna give you a copy a signed
copy of Chris Hogan's number one
best-selling book guitar inspired
because that's the next chapter in your
story - to build wealth and live like no
one else so you can give and live like
no one else and I have a feeling you're
gonna do that you guys have done very
very well what an incredible story all
right it's Dan and Rachel from Kansas
City a hundred and thirty four thousand
dollars paid off over ten years making
63 up to 100
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream here we go three two one praise
God
good job well done you guys
very very well done hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
you can do this you know that really is
a message whether you've got two hundred
seventy thousand dollars in student loan
debt or 27 thousand well you've got a
fifty thousand dollar income a five
hundred thousand dollar economy